let's find out what the rest of the
world is saying about this summit senior
foreign affairs correspondent Greg
Powell khat is live this morning about
3,000 miles away north of here in Seoul
the soon to happen summit in Singapore
involving president dropping North
Korean leader kim jong hoon getting the
attention of the world I believe the two
leaders need to be credited for the
courage with which they decided to move
forward with the summit longtime North
Korean ally China which has a definite
stake in the talks also weighing in on a
new hope it will push forward the
process of denuclearization and
political settlement on the Peninsular
issue as well as South Korea president
moon jae-in has played a critical role
through his own summits with kim leading
up to these talks turn on they both
expectin hope that tomorrow's summit
will definitely be successful feeling's
echoed by moon in a 40-minute phone
conversation Monday with President Trump
he later also warned however that the
summit could be just the start of a
diplomatic process that could take years
and there are other summit Eve worries
for the peninsula what if any reference
will be made to an end to the Korean War
halted decades ago with just an
armistice what security guarantees
possibly offered to the north by the
u.s. might mean to some 28,000 US troops
here how far is the North willing to go
to get rid of the nuclear threat to the
region and what will be said about the
horrendous human rights record of the
Pyongyang regime one time North Korean
detainee korean-american Kenneth BAE has
hopes about that I think it's very
important to see that humanitarian human
rights issues need to be addressed at
this summit while there is now attention
being given by North Korean state media
to the summit activities of its leader
across the border in South Korea there
is grudging respect for an
unconventional US president who helped
bring about this one-on-one summit from
that
this man is a revolutionary in a sense I
mean the revolutionary piece I mean he's
he's done something that nobody else's
has been willing to do South Korean
president moon also noted that it is
president rums a birthday on Thursday
and what a great present it would be if
the summit went well over to you
chairman Kim Brett Craig back I live in
Seoul
Gregg thank you